so earlier this week we had a discussion
about the narcissism of minor
differences and I explained that it's
really important on the one hand not to
ignore significant political differences
between people between candidates on
issues but at the same time we want to
make sure that we don't fall into a trap
of making relatively small differences
into a bigger deal than they need to be
at the possible risk of hurting our own
movements this was in the context of not
just the 2020 election but we talked
about that and it turns out that it was
extraordinarily timely for me to talk
about that at the beginning of the week
because this is very quickly becoming a
real issue in the 2020 primary now that
we have more serious contenders for the
2020 Democratic nomination there are
multiple overlapping disinformation
campaigns that are in full swing
specifically to divide the left some are
more coordinated than others others are
sort of more ad hoc or de-facto
disinformation campaigns and I'm going
to tell you what's going on and who is
doing it is a little bit less clear
right now although we are learning more
and more about that every single day so
the first question is who is primarily
being targeted by these disinformation
campaigns and it's primarily Kamala
Harris Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders
and interestingly bethe O'Rourke who's
not actually even a declared candidate
right now he's not even said that he's
running for president in 2020 those are
the primary four targets of these
disinformation campaigns the campaigns
are primarily happening on Twitter
reddit they are stemming partially from
4chan and are also visible on YouTube as
well as just in the comment sections of
news websites that are reporting on
these campaigns and possible campaigns
tactics that are being used these will
be familiar to many of you
tactic number one distort the positions
of candidates so that comparing them
becomes more difficult because you're
comparing them based on false no
as to what their positions are tactic
number one tactic number two spread
insulting memes ad homonyms and son in
some cases they're not even really at
homonyms in the sense that they are
argument critiques on the basis of
personal characteristics sometimes
they're just insults not connected to
any particular policy number three
foment hashtags that are critical and or
insulting of the candidates using a
specific cluster of accounts that has
been identified by a number of different
data trackers online in the specifics in
the particulars a lot of these campaigns
are racially oriented one example for
just to give you one data point was the
idea that in remember that New Year's
Eve roughly around New Year's Eve
Elizabeth Warren Instagram stream where
she had a beer one of the false claims
was that she had visible during that
stream a blackface doll in the
background it simply wasn't true and
this was used to try to start creating
racial tensions around Elizabeth
Warren's campaign for example now before
people email me angrily saying no no
David those weren't BOTS or coordinated
campaigns or shills that was me I'm not
a bot I genuinely thought I don't know
Elizabeth Warren had a blackface doll on
camera behind her that may be true but
that doesn't counteract the reality that
a number of these data science firms
including guardians AI has specifically
identified a cluster of accounts that
are posting and amplifying certain memes
and stories in a very coordinated effort
there are accounts that are the same
accounts identified as spreading
misinformation during the 2018 midterm
run up and participating in a lot of the
same stuff and shockingly 2 to 15% of
all Twitter mentions of some of these
candidates originated from this cluster
of only 200 accounts which is just an
incredibly small number to be
responsible for this amount of the memes
and
disinformation and then of course they
become amplified by a broader group of
accounts according to one analysis about
10,000 accounts then further amplifying
these disinformation messages so far
this could be because of when she
announced Kamala Harris has been
targeted the most with both a sexist and
racist messages beta or Roarke was
accused of using racist language in an
answering machine message years and
years ago when Elizabeth Warren
announced there was a ton of bots like
activity on Facebook and Twitter
targeting her a lot of it originated on
4chan on 8chan so I think the important
thing to keep in mind here Pat is that
this is not entirely coordinated there
are some identifiable discreet efforts
to focus on one candidate or another
candidate the total impact of this the
coordinated and the more ad hoc stuff
the problem with it is that it's
spreading false information that's not
good
but it has the effect of not just
pitting Democratic voters against each
other in an unproductive way it's
pitting Democratic voters against each
other on the basis of false stories and
that's why it's so dangerous yeah and I
don't know if you would call this fake
news per se but if it's not it's very
similar and you know Donald Trump was
the primary beneficiary of fake news
back in 2016 ironic because he always
seems to rail against it even though
he's talking about when he talks about
fake news it's really just news that he
disagrees with story run by the New York
Times or The Washington Post poster what
have you it looks like he may be the
primary beneficiary again of fake news
in 2020 every indication that at least
so far that would be the net effect of
this carried - it's sort of full
conclusion we have every indication that
some of this is foreign but some of it
is domestic and some of it is coming
from Democratic partisans who are trying
to sort of preemptively discredit
particular candidates before the
Democratic primary really even gets
going in earnest with debates and and
the like the most depressing part of all
of this for me is that this stuff works
right if the landscape that we had were
one where disinformation didn't spread
wasn't effective we really wouldn't have
to worry about
this so much but this stuff works we've
got anti-vaxxers people who deny climate
change we have people who believe the
most outrageous things and fall for the
silliest disinformation yes they exist
more on the right but this stuff
actually matters and it impacts the left
and we've got to stay on top of it one
of the days sponsors is privacy dot-com
/ Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy com
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy com icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link